Paulo's like this are found only on
Mercury the irregular depressions are
formed when there is an up gassing on
the planet's surface
messenger discovered these and other
features on the surface of the innermost
planet in our solar system mercury is
three times closer to the Sun and earth
is when the NASA probe arrived back in
2008 more than half of the planet's
surface was completely uncharted over a
period of four years messenger carefully
and systematically examined the smallest
of the rocky planets it had seven
instruments on board over the course of
the mission flybys got closer and closer
and the probe was able to take highly
detailed images other systems analyzed
the planet in different wavelengths the
camera tells you the overall design and
structure the spectrometer tells you
something about the mineral composition
and the atomic composition of the
atmosphere it's a very very thin
atmosphere called an exosphere at
Mercury the most pressing questions the
researchers wanted to answer were how
did the planet form and how has it
changed over time mercury is remarkable
in many ways for instance it's subjected
to radiation levels ten times what they
are here on earth a day on the blasted
planet lasts 176 Earth days but a year
only lasts half as long mercury is
pretty small just a little larger than
our moon on the side facing the Sun
temperatures can rise to about 430
degrees Celsius on the dark side they
can plunge to minus 170 putting together
a giant digital puzzle from thousands of
images the researchers on the team
painstakingly constructed a map of the
planet in different spectra that data
allowed them to make a mineralogical
survey of the surface the map is helping
the researchers understand more about
how planets form and develop we can't
determine that here on earth because we
have water and erosion in other words
the original state was altered again and
again but on Mercury you don't have that
you can still see the material that
terrestrial planets were originally made
of the biggest surprise was that
Mercury's surface differs in a key way
from the other rocky planets it contains
large amounts of volatile elements like
sulfur and chlorine the mission also
settled another question that has
plagued generations of researchers was
the planet at some point volcanic smooth
valleys like this were certainly formed
by sheets of hot quickly spreading lava
in 2012 messenger also made a remarkable
discovery at the planets northern Pole
at the bottom of craters that are always
in shadow buried beneath a dark layer of
material that also contains organic
molecules the probe detected ice both
could have been brought here by
asteroids or comets Wanderers from the
far reaches of the solar system that at
one point slammed into the planet's
surface
if all goes as planned mercury will soon
be receiving another visitor from Earth
in 2017 a joint European Japanese
mission called Pepe Colombo made up of
two satellites will liftoff for the
inner solar system to pick up where
messenger left off